après le graphe place à la littérature
plusieurs milliers de visiteurs et près
de 160 auteurs présents à chanceux près
loches pour la 27e édition de la forêt
du livre ce rendez-vous littéraire fondé
par Gonzague Saint-Brice parmi eux de
nombreuses stars de télé des
journalistes des politiques les
passerelles sont en effet nombreuses
avec la littérature il participe à la
renommée de l'événement et l'événement
permet de découvrir une autre facette de
leur personnalité Florent Clavel
c'est pour vous c'est pour la famille
c'est pour Bruce Toussaint c'est une
première l'un des visages les plus
connus du PAF n'avait jamais mis les
pieds à sous préloche et pour cause
heureusement elle n'a pas souffert une
histoire personnelle et son tout premier
livre c'est une expérience passionnante
de d'abord intellectuellement et de
décrire c'est un exercice voilà
passionnant ensuite découvert le monde
de l'édition j'ai adoré ça et puis les
rencontres encore une fois avec les
lecteurs journalistes écrivain écrivain
journaliste les passerelles sont
nombreuses la Forêt des Livres en a
d'ailleurs fait sa marque de fabrique
cette année encore le tableau de chasse
est impressionnant d'Éric nolo à
Guillaume Oda en passant par Chloé
nabedian mais aussi l'ilia Hassen après
trois ans comme chroniqueuse pour
l'émission quotidien la jeune femme de
32 ans vient de recevoir le Prix du
festival pour son troisième roman
panorama c'est vrai que quand on a eu un
autre métier auparavant et qui plus
c'est public
il peut y avoir un peu trop fusion mais
dorénavant je pense qu'il y a vraiment
même 95% des messages que je reçois sont
liés à mes livres donc c'est voilà c'est
ma priorité là aujourd'hui on m'a dit
plus grand bien de son livre notamment
ma librairie indépendante on a beaucoup
parlé et donc du coup c'était l'occasion
de la rencontrer aujourd'hui et puis il
y a le genre tout terrain entre télé
politique et écriture 48 heures après
l'université d'été de la France
insoumise Ségolène Royal est présente
pour la promotion de son livre refuser
la cruauté du monde avant sa rentrée
dans l'émission de Cyril Hanouna j'ai
pas besoin de me définir je fais les
choses comme je les sens comme elle me
plaisent continuer à donner du bonheur
autour de soi de défendre des idées à
mon avis fondamentales pour les jeunes
générations politiques médias et
littérature un cocktail qui fait ses
preuves cette année encore les écrivains
chez Gonzague Saint-Brice ont attiré des
milliers de visiteurs